right now hey but she just starts
drawing all over everything
yeah I grow four feet first team to get
three points wins if you guys both get
three points then they'll do a sudden
gasp number can paint me red the fact is
if you guess wrong you have to wait till
the other team makes their next guess
wait where you can guess again so you
can't just shout out now that's correct
guesses and it's incorrect used to wait
for PJ to guess before he can take
another guess fair PJ so quiet Hey
PJ's thoughtful blindfold drawing
challenge Oscars Hotel Edition yeah yeah
there's no way that's gonna fit on the
thumbnail hello everybody I'm here with
friends so they think and I think hi is
everyone excited everyone's very pensive
pensive energy yeah yeah I think when I
talk I'm very excited I'm here kick the
PJ high honor of the release of Oscars
hotel tomorrow tomorrow tomorrow this is
so you won't be I mean do you need a
diaper cream in your pan and we have
split up into two teams I call dibs on
the creator of Oscars hotel so stuff no
it's my video my channel is my rules I'm
an Outback Steakhouse all Grace's rules
there all right uncle in a birdcage
I'll have it my way I want Mitchell
David yeah okay so what's gonna happen
is Jack Vegas behind the camera mamrie
and I have the blindfolds jack is gonna
give us the name of a character from
Oscar's Hotel mamrie and I will
blindfold ourselves and try to draw
either from memory or just from what we
assure guessing we saw it this character
in the trailer surely they have a name
yes
the wily truck for sale we're gonna try
and draw the character to the best of
our abilities while PJ and Mitchell try
to guess the
character the first one to get a correct
gets a point the first team to three
points wins the kicker is that if you
guess incorrectly you have to wait for
the other team to make a guess before
you can guess again does that make any
sense
yes only because Jack explained yeah I
guess yeah yeah sharpies and we have
crayons which serve no purpose when
you're blindfolded question why do they
make a blindfold with a with a smells
Ariana knows right yeah oh I thought I
don't know so you can't smell the
crayons to tell what color you're
picking up so you can't see I think
we're overthinking this I got those I
got those for free when I fly uh way to
share with shorts for airplane for tea
yeah exactly it's a perfect umm yeah you
look great it's like those charcoal
panties for your nose you know babies
look a little bit like old immortal icon
yeah Harry I am your father or something
I don't watch it
I am your I is e well now they're [ __ ]
getting everything now yeah it's like
gonna be farther
kill Harry yeah he killed it
you guys are eyes look away oh my god
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna know who it
is Oh God what the know every seems like
I am are you guys ready yes can we look
yes good luck get set yeah I bid go okay
okay have you charged all right I know
about it bring house I saw cheese and I
thought mouse
I now I see eyes and your Creator feeds
all damn day is that pizza guy it's a
guy it used to be a character he was so
actually good and I was so close to
being in it hanging out [ __ ] make sure
you knew how much cheese
okay well the sharpies we just can't be
yeah we can okay ridiculous I had an
issue you said that we had to wait to
guess who was first
oh no you can guess first but if it's
been about corrective - wait wait till
the next person oh sure like I know what
I know cuz yeah I raised my hand like
fool like a damn fool like a fool
all right again I added I can do have on
that yeah I'll make it look great yeah
yes well debatable but yes you're us oh
my god I'm not in a who did okay got it
no oh okay wait no I'm just opening the
lid set go I believe in you grace hey
come on what's that what is that that's
a golf wait a shock kit oh okay I see it
now because now the mouth and defense
oh hey yeah I got that tattoo I always
liked the fish of Jesus and look at it I
just go dog today when you're sick dog
which character you I know that's what I
was just like your finest little Dean
Dobbs a shot oh my sad or god that's so
unfair looks like Hitler I didn't well I
see an adorable schoolboy shock let's
say like an evil labor though yeah
there's a lot wrong with you okay is it
one over right now it's one on time
right super tired okay my anxiety yeah
my hos I guess it is tingling I'm
sweating leaf useless yeah we have very
similar styles and going for I know it's
like we don't know what the actual
character looks like but we do work like
that word here we go next one you guys
eyes closed who I'm Dartmouth I mean to
you come on Nick Oh cousin okay here we
go
all right ready a half set go Oh Queen B
Oh No Julian Troy can issue a Mickey
Mouse tennis shoe oh yeah that looks
great I think potato is great gosh okay
we got this okay it's two to one
oh there we go where we just done no
okay mother ready
please trees are really ambiguous I'm
hey okay can i I'm gonna open a ready on
my mark get set go
oh she's correct yeah I spotted where
the crayon is who watch behind
yes she said all right I'm John Arab
Mitchell he's like dumbass idiot baby
[ __ ] I'm dog dog dog I like the door
behind it I would not got that I know I
thought I was like I it's gonna point to
Mimi but I knew she looked at the red
also she spots I was like because it was
like this no no this is the game that
way oh my god
all right ready okay cries how my man's
got this okay you're gonna be wait can
we open all right yes you guys can open
your eyes all right stop tough look the
trash out nothing I got nothing okay you
saw what she drew yeah already you so
much it drew I can't guess again
yeah you've said yo you've said we know
say that's that cows that cabs sure at
least guess a character ginger ooh yeah
no he gets Wiener wiener ha ha big words
he's the dog - we all laugh I will go
ahead go one more round
all right all right I'll get I'll give
you half a point because of that
Gentiles injury I'm gonna go out on a
limb here and say that if we told
hipsters these were Basquiat drawings oh
yes yeah nice book girlfriend literally
ten
thousands of dollars two to two and a
half classic bit more intense I'm needed
I'm sweaty huh okay okay I got this draw
the character Raleigh here she's got him
yep can we look at go okay okay
permit her me incorrect oh okay let me
take my time let me know I know I know
who that is
I'm gonna let you go oh [ __ ] I know it
is oh I'm gonna let grateful oh I know
exactly who it is I'm sorry baby I plan
a date well uh BJ could that by any
chance be right yeah play by Megan Rings
play by Megan makes it looks exactly
like Megan right I thought of your shell
I thought of the show yeah hey look this
looks identical so no surprise here we
win I think that means we want that your
misery one who really wins after a
wiener is shouted from Alou be fair
though uh it's I come on the show to
lose at drama games I know that's just
something I do well this was really fun
and if you want to listen to more fun
make sure you go listen to the full
podcast with all of these guys or we
talked in depth ly about Oscars hotel
and answer some of your questions about
the process of making it and make sure
you go subscribe to all of these people
across the internet Oscar's Hotel comes
out tomorrow September 15 literally like
a stays back Jack Jack Jack Jack Oscars
Hotel series dog our Oscars hotels
Carrie's guy um Oscar so gel series calm
tomorrow September 15 go check it out oh
man
yep this is why none of us do sports we
do art I don't know thank you isn't that
a thing Jack check that yeah I think
you're thinking of the t-shirts of
things the t-shirts they because they
make t-shirts for both teachers aren't
tattoo wait a sec we've been over that
you're telling me that you guys have
seen how chewing
clothes on everyday yeah my nipples are
out